Have you ever, you know, stopped
and wondered if the news you're
seeing right here at home could
maybe be influenced subtly by
our own government?
Like in ways similar to how
other countries push their
messages abroad.
It's a really interesting
question, maybe a bit unsettling
at first glance.
Right.
But it actually leads us down
this fascinating path, looking
into a really pivotal bit of
American law and history.
It really does.
So today we're doing a deep dive
into the Smith Munde Act.
This was a month landmark law
from way back in 1948, and it
was basically America's original
firewall against the government
pushing its own messages
domestically.
Yeah, the no domestic propaganda
rule, essentially.
Exactly.
So our mission here is to unpack
how this law built up that wall,
that barrier between U.S.
government info campaigns and
the American public.
And then, crucially, look at how
it's rollback in 2013 pretty
much blurred those lines,
especially now, you know, in the
digital age.
It's not just some dusty old
law.
It really gets to the heart of
trust, information flow, and
this new reality.
We're in this sort of borderless
information war.
And for this deep dive, we're
leaning heavily on some great
source material, right?
Specifically, an analysis of the
ACT itself.
Yes, exactly.
A detailed analysis by Chris
Abraham which really helps trace
the law's journey.
You know, from its post World
War Two start all the way
through its big update, the
modernization.
So it gives that context the
changes how it all fits into the
bigger picture of global
information stuff.
It really does.
It provides that historical
backdrop, the legislative nitty
gritty, and helps us see how a
country like the US, committed
to democracy and openness, has
tried to handle the sheer power
of information both outwards on
the world stage and inwards at
home.
OK, so let's dive in.
Let's go back to 1948.
Can you paint a picture for us?
What was the world like then,
and how did that whole
atmosphere lead to this act
being created?
Absolutely.
So picture this the world's
still catching its breath after
World War 2A, war that showed
brutally just how powerful
psychological warfare and mass
communication could be.
Yeah, the impact was huge.
Huge.
And even as things settled, a
new fight was brewing.
The Cold War, this big
ideological struggle.
And everyone understood that
information, strategic
messaging, well, it was going to
be a weapon just as potent as
any tank or bomb.
Makes sense.
So the US Information and
Educational Exchange Act, that's
its official name.
Soon known as Smith, Munt was
born right into that climate.
Lawmakers had the lessons of
wartime propaganda fresh in
their minds.
Very fresh.
So the need to project American
values, push back against the
Soviet bloc, ideas that must
have been front and center.
A clear external focus for the
ACT then.
Precisely.
The main goal stated right up
front was external.
It gave the US government,
mostly the State Department, the
green light to create and spread
information and cultural
programs abroad.
OK, so things like promoting
American values, democracy,
countering what other nations
were saying.
Exactly.
Think of it as America's big
global PR push.
Winning hearts and minds,
building understanding, shoring
up alliances.
It let agencies like the Voice
of America VOA broadcast widely.
We share news, American culture
with people overseas.
But here's a fascinating bit,
maybe the most important part of
the original act.
It allowed this outward push.
But what was the crucial
counterbalance?
Second part The safeguard they
insisted on for messages aimed
inward at Americans.
And that's where they do that
really clear line.
The ACT explicitly forbade,
using those same tools, the
messages the techniques
developed for foreign audiences,
turning them inward on the
American public.
So it wasn't just a side note.
Oh no, not at all.
It was a core principle, a
deliberate legal barrier.
They wanted to shield U.S.
citizens from their own
government's messaging machine
inside the country.
Lawmakers got it.
The power to shape opinions
abroad could easily become the
power to manipulate at home.
And they absolutely wanted to
prevent that.
And this ban wasn't just
theoretical, it came straight
from the hard lessons of World
War 2, right?
What specific examples of
wartime propaganda really stuck
with lawmakers?
Absolutely.
The logic was very practical.
Learn the hard way.
During the war, the US saw first
hand from both sides, Allied and
Axis, just how potent propaganda
could be, almost terrifyingly
so.
Shaping morale, public opinion,
even firing up or demoralizing
troops did.
You give some examples.
Sure, take the Axis side.
You have the infamous Tokyo
Rose.
Actually a few different English
speaking women broadcasting for
Radio Tokyo.
Their shows were insidious.
They'd play popular American
Music, then weave in cynical
comments about the war, about
soldiers, wives back home being
unfaithful.
It was pure psychological
warfare playing on fear and
loneliness.
Wow, that's dark.
And then you had Nazi Germany's
Lord haha William Joyce.
He broadcast in English to
Britain.
He was clever, mixing bits of
truth like reporting actual
bombing phase with demoralizing
spins and exaggerations trying
to create panic.
So division.
These weren't just news reports,
they were calculated psyops.
It's chilling to think about
that direct psychological
impact.
But it wasn't just the access
using these tools, right?
The allies had their own
information operations, too.
How did that play into the US
thinking?
Right.
The Allies were also effective.
Britain's BBC World Service, for
instance.
It became this vital source of
credible news in Nazi occupied
Europe.
It was a powerful counter to
Nazi propaganda, offering a
steady, factual voice that
boosted morale and shaped
opinion.
So the US saw this power wanted
its own tools for the global
information fight.
Exactly.
But they also recognize the
danger.
If foreign enemies could
manipulate populations with
information, imagine how much
more effective, how much more
dangerous that manipulation
could be if it came from your
own government.
So that was the core fear,
domestic manipulation.
How do they think that would
damage public trust if it wasn't
prevented?
That was the absolute part of
it.
Lawmakers deeply understood that
if agencies like the State
Department, maybe even the CIA,
could legally run info campaigns
inside the US, it would just
shred public trust.
Trust in government, yes, but
also, crucially, trust in the
media.
How so?
Well, think about it.
If people couldn't tell the
difference between independent
news reporting and stuff
produced or pushed by the
government, every news story,
every piece of information
becomes suspect, right?
How could you trust what you
read or heard if you thought
your own government might be
behind it, trying to sway you?
So it was about protecting that
separation between independent
journalism, which is supposed to
hold power accountable, right,
and government communication,
which could easily slide into
propaganda.
Precisely.
It was about building and
keeping that public trust.
The fear was that blurring those
lines would erode the very
foundation of an informed public
in a democracy.
They wanted a legal guarantee,
basically, that Americans could
assume their government wasn't
making the news or entertainment
they consumed at home just to
shape their politics.
And this firewall, as our source
calls it, wasn't just symbolic,
it was strict.
Incredibly strict, designed to
be a real bureaucratic wall.
The rules were super clear,
meant to enforce that
separation, keep the domestic
information space, you know,
clean.
For instance, Voice of America,
VOA, a key part of US
international messaging, could
beam its shows, its news, its
cultural stuff into places like
Cuba, the USSR, China.
No problem.
But.
But, and this is the kicker,
they were legally banned from
broadcasting that exact same
content into, say, Kansas.
Wow.
Not to Kansas.
It was a strict geographic and
legal line, not just a
suggestion.
That level of deliberate
separation is amazing.
So US embassies overseas could
hand out pamphlets about
democracy, American value.
It's really to foreign
population.
But those same pamphlets
couldn't legally be given out in
Los Angeles.
No, not in LA, not anywhere in
the US.
It wasn't just broadcast, it was
any information material created
by the government for foreign
eyes and ears.
It was kept behind this this
wall.
So there was this explicit is it
legal promise baked into the law
that Americans were shielded
from their own government's info
campaigns?
You could assume the news at
home wasn't government produced
spin.
Exactly.
It was seen as fundamental to an
open, democratic society, a
really core principle back then,
OK.
Let's jump forward now, decades
later, from the tight controls
of 1948 to the completely
different world of, say, 2013.
What was the main thing that
changed everything, especially
how information moved around the
globe?
Oh hands down.
It was the Internet and the
explosion of digital
communication that came with it.
This wasn't just a small tweak,
it was a revolution.
It basically smashed those old
geographic firewalls.
Right, the old rules just didn't
fit anymore.
Not at all.
Rules designed for radio waves
and paper pamphlets started
looking really outdated.
Kind of like trying to use a
typewriter in the age of e-mail.
Information that used to be
contained by broadcast range or
physical delivery could now zip
across the planet instantly.
Made the old legal lines really
hard to maintain.
And this borderless information
flow created what people started
calling the boomerang effect.
Can you explain that what it
looked?
Like, sure, the boomerang effect
is basically when content made
for a foreign audience
inevitably finds its way back
into the US.
So imagine VOA produces a video,
maybe something tailored for an
Afghan radio station, right?
Talking about an American view
on a local issue, or maybe a
cultural exchange.
OK, before the Internet, that
video mostly stayed where it was
intended.
But by 2013, that same video
gets uploaded to YouTube, or
maybe a VOA article gets posted
on their website, and instantly
it's not just for Afghans
anymore.
Anyone anywhere can see it,
including someone sitting in
Cleveland, OH.
And social media just threw
gasoline on that fire, right?
Yeah.
Made it even harder to control
where things ended.
UP totally amplified it.
It wasn't even about someone
actively looking for it anymore.
By 2013 social media algorithms
weren't checking passports, they
were pushing stuff based on
engagement.
So a VOA piece meant for Central
Asia, if it got popular there,
got shared.
The algorithm could push it into
American feeds.
Exactly without anyone in the US
ever requesting it.
A friend abroad shares a link.
A new site picks it up.
The content was essentially
pulling itself into the domestic
space.
The old legal barrier designed
for a world where you pushed
information out.
It just became kind of
irrelevant.
How do you stop information
crossing borders when the
borders are digital and
everything's shareable?
So this practical problem, this
boomerang, it obviously sparked
a big debate about the Smith
Munn Act itself.
What were the main arguments
from people who wanted to change
the law?
Well, the supporters of change
basically argued, look, this old
rule is meaningless in the age
of Facebook and Twitter.
They felt pretending the wall
still worked when digital
reality had poked it full of
holes was frankly naive.
So better to just admit reality.
Their core argument was exactly
that transparency was better
than pretending the wall still
existed.
If the content was already out
there, accessible to anyone
online, why keep a law that
didn't match reality?
They thought it was better to be
upfront, let the content to be
openly available instead of
having it sweep back in
unofficially.
But the critics, they saw it
very differently.
They weren't just seeing a
practical adjustment.
They saw a real danger, right?
What were their big fears?
Oh yeah, Opponents were deeply
concerned.
They use phrases like opening
the floodgates.
They saw it as giving a legal
green light for U.S. government
propaganda to be consumed by its
own citizen.
Chinese wall was gone, they
said.
Exactly that clear legal
separation between foreign
messaging and the domestic
infosphere?
Gone.
Their worry wasn't just about
access, it was about
legitimizing that access.
They feared that killing the ban
would normalize Americans
consuming government made
messages, potentially dulling
critical thinking and damaging
trust in independent media even
further.
A really fundamental worry about
the integrity of our information
environment here at home.
Which leads us right to the
change itself, the Smith Mont.
Modernization Act of 2012.
It took effect in July 2013.
How did this actually change the
rules on the ground?
Well, it pretty much dismantled
the old domestic ban.
It legally allowed the State
Department and the US Agency for
Global Media, USA, GM, the
agency that overseas VOA, Radio
Free Europe, Radio Liberty, et
cetera.
It used to be the Broadcasting
Board of Governors.
It allowed them to make their
foreign focused content
available inside the United
States.
This was huge.
A 70 year old legal firewall
officially torn down.
It was no longer illegal for an
American citizen to tune into a
VOA broadcast, even if it was
made for, say, North Africa.
Now, there was that specific
phrase in the law upon request,
but even with that wording, the
lines blurred almost instantly,
didn't they?
How did that upon request part
become, well, practically
meaningless?
It really did upon request.
Sounded like it kept some
barrier up, like you had to
actively seek it out.
But in the digital world it
doesn't really work that way.
If VOA puts a story on YouTube,
is clicking on it in your feed
really requesting it?
In the old sense, probably not.
Anyone anywhere can find it with
a search, click a link someone
shared, or just have it pop up
thanks to an algorithm.
Social media algorithms don't
care if you requested it.
They push what's popular or what
they think you'll click on.
So basically the content became
available everywhere online by
default upon request.
Ended up being more of a legal
formality than a real practical
hurdle.
You used that analogy before the
export, only beer or soda.
Can you flesh that out a bit
more?
How does it show the shift after
2013?
Yeah, I think it helps clarify
things before 2013.
Think of America's propaganda
vintage.
It's info and cultural stuff
designed to promote US values
abroad as strictly for export,
like a special beer brewed only
for international markets,
legally barred from being sold
at home.
Americans were supposed to get
their news and info from private
independent media, a clear
separation.
The Smith Munt Act was the law
keeping the export brew off the
domestic shelves.
And sometimes those export
versions might even have
different ingredients right
tailored for a specific foreign
taste.
The point was separation.
Exactly.
Different ingredients because
the purpose was different.
Domestic audiences were meant to
get their view of the world from
independent sources, free from
government strategic spin.
But after 2013, that export
product could also be sold at
home.
And that's the core worry for
critics.
That's the crux of it, they
argue.
It risks diluting public trust,
eroding the separation between
government PR and independent
journalism.
If the government is now allowed
to put content out there that
Americans can consume, how do
people tell the difference?
How do you evaluate something
that looks like news but
actually came from a government
agency with a specific goal in
mind?
While their proponents would
say, look, it's naive to think a
separation still existed anyway
given the Internet, But the
question lingers for a lot of
people.
What's the psychological impact?
What does it do to trust in
Media, Trust in government info,
when that legal firewall is just
gone?
It feeds into this wider issue
with some experts call a crisis
of epistemic trust.
When that line blurs, even well
meaning government messages can
start to look suspicious.
It forces you, the listener, to
constantly ask, is this real
news or is it spin?
Is it independent or is it
designed to influence me?
That sounds exhausting.
It is this constant need for
vigilance, for source checking,
everything.
It breeds cynicism not just
about government, but about all
information sources.
And that cynicism unfortunately
makes people more vulnerable to
actual disinformation from
anywhere.
Because the old markers of
what's trustworthy feel less
reliable.
The ground feels less solid.
This really hits at a
fundamental aspect of state
power itself, doesn't it?
Propaganda or strategic
messaging?
It's as much a tool in the
state's toolkit as the military
or the economy.
Is it fair to say every country
does this?
Oh absolutely.
Propaganda, if we use the broad
definition strategic messaging
to shape opinions, interactions,
is a universal statecraft tool.
It's fundamental to how nations
operate internally and
externally.
Though governments prefer other
terms.
Right, definitely.
They'll often use public
diplomacy or strategic
communication, especially for
overseas stuff, to avoid the
negative baggage of propaganda.
But the core idea is influenced
through information highlighting
values, building understanding,
countering rivals.
Nations just differ in how open
they are about it and the
specific methods they use, but
they all do it.
It's a constant part of
international relations.
And within that, there's the
concept of soft power, coined by
Joseph Nye, not about force, but
attraction.
Exactly.
Joseph Nye's idea of soft power
is a nation's ability to get
others to want what it wants,
not by threatening them or
paying them, but by making its
culture, its values, its
policies seem attractive and
legitimate, its persuasion
through appeal.
Like Hollywood movies or music?
That's a classic example.
The global appeal of American
pop culture can project an image
of dynamism, freedom, making
American ideals seem
aspirational.
That kind of subtle influence
can often achieve more long term
than military threats or
economic sanctions.
And during the Cold War, the US
went all in on soft power,
didn't it?
Billions invested.
What were some key examples?
Massive investment think about
the big radio operations Radio
Free Europe started in 1950.
It beamed uncensored news
analysis culture into Soviet
controlled Eastern Europe.
It was a lifeline, offering an
alternative to state media
telling people news from their
own countries that they're
governments were suppressing.
Giving them a connection to the
outside.
Right.
Then there was Radio Liberty
from 53, aimed right at the
Soviet Union itself, trying to
foster dissent.
Paint a picture of a different
reality.
These weren't just news shows.
There were deliberate counter
narratives pushing freedom,
democracy, prosperity,
everything the Soviets stood
against.
And it wasn't only radio.
There were more direct tactics
to information warfare.
Absolutely.
Beyond the broadcast, you have
tactical information warfare,
often called psychological
operations or psyops.
During Vietnam, for example, the
US military dropped tons of
leaflets over North Vietnam and
Vietcong areas.
What did the leaflets say?
Messages designed to demoralize
enemy troops, encourage them to
defect, explain US goals.
Sometimes they even included
safe conduct passes for
surrender.
It was a whole spectrum
approach, mixing strategic
messaging with battlefield
tactics.
But soft power was broader than
just psyops, right?
Cultural diplomacy played a huge
role.
Huge cultural diplomacy was key.
You had the Fulbright program
started in 46, sending scholars
back and forth, fostering
understanding, showcasing
American openness, a subtle but
powerful counter to Soviet
claims about America being
closed off.
And the cultural exports?
Jazz tours.
Oh yeah, iconic jazz tours with
people like Louis Armstrong,
Dave Brubeck, hugely popular
behind the Iron Curtain.
They conveyed this sense of
American freedom creativity that
really resonated.
Plus Hollywood films showing
individual success, consumer
plenty, even agricultural shows
displaying American tech and
abundance, all designed to send
a message about American
freedom, innovation, prosperity,
often more effective because it
didn't feel like government
propaganda.
Of course, the US wasn't the
early one playing this game.
It's global.
Other countries have their own
playbooks.
Absolutely.
It's universal.
Britain, for example, has the
BBC World Service, its global
flagship broadcaster.
They position it carefully as
independent news in dozens of
languages.
But it serves British interest.
Undoubtedly, while maintaining
journalistic standards, IT
projects an image of British
stability, reliability,
democracy.
It's often a go to news source
in places where local media is
weak or controlled.
In America's rivals.
Russia, you see similar moves.
Russia had Radio Moscow back in
the Soviet days.
Later they launched RT Russia
Today, basically the Soviet and
Russian versions of the same
game.
What was their aim?
Radio Moscow was the Kremlin's
voice pushing the party line,
criticizing the West.
RT Post Cold War presents itself
as an alternative news source,
often highlighting Western
problems, platforming dissenting
voices.
A more subtle way to question
the dominant western narrative
project their worldview
sometimes stir up trouble in
rival countries and.
China's got a massive global
media footprint now.
Huge CGTN, the China Global
Television Network, is Beijing's
official mouthpiece worldwide,
promoting China's economy,
culture, pushing back against
criticism on human rights or
geopolitics, and more recently,
you have the TikTok and WeChat
ecosystems.
Not just apps.
Not just apps, they're powerful
cultural influence channel with
state linked content moderation.
The algorithms, the rules about
what gets seen or suppressed,
can subtly align with Beijing
views, influencing global
perceptions on a massive scale,
often without users even
realizing it.
Then you have the really overt
stuff like N Koreas border, loud
speakers for decades blasting
propaganda South.
But you mentioned something
interesting for our 2025
timeline.
They dismantled the last one,
yeah.
Reportedly dismantled the last
one on the border in 2025.
It's fascinating.
For decades those speakers were
a constant, unavoidable fixture
on the DMZ.
Very direct loud psychological
warfare, patriotic songs, anti
US stuff praising the Kims.
So why stop now?
Well, it might signal a slight
thaw in relations in that
specific spot, but it probably
also shows that even North Korea
recognizes that in the age of
digital media everywhere, a
static loudspeaker, however
noisy, is less effective than
maybe more subtle digital
campaigns.
It might reflect a shift in
their own info strategy
following the global trend
towards digital.
It really drives home to the
point propaganda, strategic
communication, whatever you call
it, it's just part of how states
operate, always has been.
Exactly a universal tool.
The methods change, the
transparency varies, but the
game continues.
OK, let's try and map this out
historically.
Put it on a timeline, See how
information warfare and global
messaging evolved, adapting to
world events and new tech.
We can start right back at WWI,
right?
The WWI foundations, roughly 41
to 45. the US set up the Office
of War Information, the OWI.
It was huge, making films, radio
shows, posters, leaflets and
critically aimed at both foreign
audiences and Americans at home.
So unified messaging during the
war.
Totally.
Domestically, it was about
morale, explaining the war,
pushing, rationing unity
internationally, countering
enemy propaganda, rallying
allies, centralized info control
that you know people would
question later in peacetime.
And Voice of America VOA started
then too, in 42.
What was its immediate job?
VOA's first job was urgent
broadcast news into access
territory.
Their famous first line was the
news may be good or it may be
bad.
We shall tell you the truth, a
direct shot and not see in
Japanese lies.
They wanted to give an American
perspective, counter enemy
stories, give facts to people
under occupation, undermine
morale, encourage resistance.
And the allies like Britain's
BBC Overseas service.
Crucial the BBC was that vital
credible voice in occupied
Europe, accurate news, coded
messages for resistance
fighters, boosting morale,
really set a standard for
international broadcasting,
while, as we said, the Axis had
Tokyo Rose and Lord haha doing
their psychological warfare
thing.
OK, Fast forward to the early
Cold War 46 to 60.
We get the Smith Munt Act in 48,
that legal wall against domestic
dissemination.
We talked about setting the
rules for the new Cold War info
fight.
Exactly, And the US ramps up
broadcasts at its new
adversaries.
Radio Free Europe RFE starts in
50 aiming at Eastern Bloc
countries Uncensored news,
culture stuff their own
governments were hiding, keeping
hope alive, offering an
alternative.
And Radio Liberty.
RL followed in 53 and right at
the Soviet Union itself,
broadcasting in loads of
languages across that vast
empire.
Plus, the US poured money into
cultural diplomacy, jazz tours,
art shows, Fulbright
scholarships, all subtle ways to
showcase American values,
freedom, creativity, countering
the Soviet narrative.
Well, the Soviets had Radio
Moscow and Tax News Agency
pushing rely globally.
Yep, Radio Moscow was the
Kremlin's voice worldwide,
nonstop praising communism,
slamming capitalism.
TSS was the official news
agency, super tightly
controlled, making sure
everything fit the party line.
Masters of spin.
And the BBC World Service just
kept growing its reputation.
Became seen as the gold standard
for many.
Reliable, less overtly
propagandistic than others.
Building trust globally.
Moving into the Vietnam era, 60s
and 70s, US psyops in Vietnam
really ramped up.
What did that involve?
Very active.
You had the Chuhoi, or Open Arms
program, using leaflets dropped
from planes, powerful loud
speakers on the ground, special
radio stations like Armed Forces
Radio, all urging Viet Cong and
N Vietnamese soldiers to defect.
Promising safety and better
treatment.
Exactly.
Promising food, medical care,
safe passage, Often featuring
testimonials from actual
defectors.
Direct tactical information
warfare aimed at breaking enemy
morale.
And other voices emerged
globally in this polarized time.
Definitely Radio Havana, Cuba,
starting in 61.
That was Castro's fiery voice,
especially across Latin America
and Africa, spreading
revolutionary ideas, supporting
liberation movements, offering a
stark alternative to the West
and China.
Radio International pushed
Maoist ideals worldwide,
challenging both the US and the
Soviets.
Real counter narratives.
Then the late Cold War, the 80s,
Reagan's Project Truth.
What was that about?
Reagan took a more aggressive
info stance.
Project Truth was about directly
confronting Soviet
disinformation, which was
getting pretty sophisticated.
The US wanted to expose Soviet
lies, highlight the contrast
with democracy, go on the
offensive ideologically.
While the Soviets doubled down
on active measures
disinformation.
Oh yeah, Active measures was
their term for all sorts of
covert influence.
Propaganda, forgeries, political
meddling.
A prime example was that
horrible false story they spread
that AIDS was AUS bioweapon.
That was a Soviet active.
Measure a major one designed
purely to damage the US image.
So mistrust.
Meanwhile, RRL expanded
broadcasting into Afghanistan
during the Soviet invasion
there, trying to counter
Moscow's narrative to the Afghan
people.
Then the Berlin Wall falls.
The Cold War ends the 90s Post
Cold War shift, the US
information agency USIA gets
disbanded.
Right in 99, it's public
diplomacy functions mostly got
folded into the State Department
signaled a shift integrating
messaging more directly with
foreign policy rather than
having a separate agency.
And we started seeing global
news and public diplomacy
blurring, like CNN and the Gulf
War.
Exactly.
CNN's live 24/7 Gulf War
coverage was revolutionary.
It gave everyone this immediate
view, but it also became this
huge public diplomacy tool.
Intended or not, the images
shaped global perception in real
time, showed how independent
media could become a channel for
influence.
And Russia, even while
struggling, started rebuilding
its international broadcasting,
laying the groundwork for RT.
Which brings us to the Internet
era and the post 911 World 2001,
2012.
New players like Al Jazeera
emerge.
Al Jazeera was a game changer,
gaining huge reach after 911.
Challenging Western narratives
about the Middle East showed
that powerful global media could
come from outside the West.
Information flow wasn't just one
way anymore.
And U.S. military information
operations expanded in Iraq and
Afghanistan.
Big time.
More localized, sophisticated
OPS, including covertly setting
up and running local radio and
TV stations trying to counter
extremist messages, win hearts
and minds, often making them
look like local outlets.
But crucially, this is when the
Smith Munt firewall really
started crumbling.
Online content posted abroad was
easily accessible at home.
The ban was becoming unworkable.
Which leads right back to the
Smith Munt Modernization Act of
2013.
Lifting the domestic ban, USAGM
could now make VOARRL content
available domestically.
And the debate raged.
As we discussed, critics feared
domestic propaganda.
Proponents said the Internet
made the ban obsolete anyway.
But the law changed.
What was forbidden was now
allowed.
Ushering in the era we might
call the social media propaganda
wars from 2014 onward, Russia's
Internet research agency, the
IRA, becomes infamous.
How do they use these platforms?
The IRA mastered social media
manipulation, not just old
school propaganda.
They created fake accounts,
bots, fake activist groups,
spreading divisive content,
amplifying extremism, targeting
US elections, using Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram to sow chaos,
exploit divisions showed how
vulnerable open societies were
online.
And China's strategy with TikTok
and WeChat?
More subtle cultural influence.
Much more subtle.
Often these platforms are huge
cultural influence channels with
state linked content moderation.
The the algorithms, the
censorship, even if not always
obvious, can shape narratives,
suppressed criticism, promote
views aligned with Beijing,
influencing potentially billions
of users, often blending
influence with entertainment.
Soft power at scale.
And then 2025, the symbolic end
of North Korea's loudspeaker
diplomacy.
Dismantling the last one.
Yeah, that's symbolic end of an
era.
Crude, loud physical propaganda
giving way completely to the
digital battlefield, even for a
regime like North Korea.
So after tracing all this
history, this evolution, what
does it actually mean for you,
the listener, right now, in
2025?
What's the bottom?
Line The bottom line is
fundamental.
The old Smith Munt world, the
one with clear borders for
information controlled channels
like radio waves and print.
That world is just.
Completely gone.
Completely Today, information,
including state sponsored
messages, is borderless.
And that's not mainly because
the law changed in 2013.
It's because the medium changed.
The Internet broke those
barriers first.
The 2013 law basically just
caught up legally, aligning the
rules with the reality.
It acknowledged the situation
technology had already created.
But the impact of that
alignment, the psychological
cost for you, the listener, it's
significant, right?
That formal guarantee, that
legal assurance that your own
government wasn't targeting you
with its info campaigns at home?
That's gone.
It is, and it fits the global
pattern we've seen for every
major power.
Now the message is potentially
for everyone, everywhere all at
once.
No neat split between foreign
and domestic anymore in the info
space so.
What does that mean practically?
It means you have a much bigger
responsibility now to be
critical to really scrutinize
the information you consume.
That default assumption that
government wasn't in this
domestic messaging game?
The assumption Smith munt
legally supported for decades?
You can't make that assumption
anymore.
So what questions should you be
asking yourself when you see
news or content online?
Constantly ask, OK, where did
this really come from?
Who made it?
Why?
What was its original purpose?
Is this independent reporting or
is it a government message,
maybe originally for overseas,
but now legally here for you to
see potentially with the
strategic goal behind it?
And how does the platform,
seeing it on Facebook, TikTok, a
new site, how does that shape
how it looks or how far it
travels?
That's the new reality.
The lines are blurred.
Government content can reach
Americans legally.
Agencies can talk to domestic
media more freely.
The global info war isn't
happening somewhere else.
It's happening right here in
your feed, on your your screen.
So wrapping this up, we've gone
from that strict 1948 band
designed to shield Americans
from government messaging at
home through decades of changing
tactics and global information
wars, right up to today's
borderless environment driven by
tech finally codified by that
2013 Modernization Act.
And it's key to remember the law
didn't create this borderless
world, it just sort of rubber
stamped the reality.
The Internet had already built
that old analog firewall.
It was leaky long before they
officially took it down.
So maybe a final thought for you
to chew on.
In this world where any state's
message can reach anyone
anywhere, and the lines between
foreign influence and domestic
news are so incredibly blurry,
how do we as a society maintain
any kind of trust in our media?
And maybe more importantly, what
new heavy responsibilities fall
on each of us individually to
constantly question, to evaluate
every single thing we see in
here, knowing that old legal
wall isn't there anymore?